how's it going bros my name is baby I
review subreddits on the internet it's
fine it's cool I'm a gamer but if
there's one sub ready that scares me
more than any sub ready it's cursed
comments cursed comments it's the worst
subreddit because it's guaranteed to get
me in trouble so grab your favorite
slurp juice and likes and freakin do
this glug look just spilled of it half a
lid on my pants for no reason
curse interview your task is to you see
what I mean I'm not reading that I'm not
I'm gonna commit bad by 2020 if I don't
have a girlfriend
don't don't tell me what to do no I was
just fixing your spelling do it looks
you forgot the APUs trough you dumbass
now go beeping your boo-boo if you're
afraid with guns just remember that even
we need the poopers aren't when you
heard a bump in the night Jesus Christ
when are the Popo many get a double shot
by we near the pool with a double-barrel
you don't have to imagine if you're in
China
I'll drink to that one
this is edgy jokes but it scares me
curse uppercut ever pluck a guy's
eyebrows and realize that they are
absolutely not superior gender and
weakest my partner's thought this until
she got an uppercut she wasn't very
superior after that cheers to that
gamers it was a joke it was a joke
YouTube that's a joke I know you added
your new harassment policy but he said
it but he said it how am I supposed to
interpret oh god these dog whistling to
other groups my boyfriend a paper
laborer a kidney stone into my hole
I'm keeping it there little yeah I'm not
reading then guys who sag their pants
below there but why easy access for
their home ace yesterday I was driving
home I was driving my exam we were
driving home and some King guy doesn't
understand the concept of pulling your
pants off up up I said up so everyone
else has to look at his butt crack and
I'm like no
I don't want to see that so I pulled
that Marta's window as we passed by and
I'm ready to go
nice ass dumb ass but she stopped me and
she says I mean and but I'm like I'm
helping I'm helping piss me off today my
psych professor said you'll never truly
know someone well enough to marry until
you've seen them struggle financially
grieve a lost one or witness them while
they're sick and that just hit the
really deep first date ideas freeze
their assets kill one of their loved
ones poisoned their dinner
checkmate how are you going to react to
this huh no reaction oh you're a
sociopath
let's go gamer lets me go make youtube
videos baby groots responds to baby Yoda
stealing a spotlight is I am Groot I
would use baby Groot as firewood to keep
baby Yoda warm I would use baby Groot as
fire to cook baby oh that for my baby
Otis to that I'm gonna drink it's going
to be delicious we're gonna make baby
Yoda flavor baby Yoda
I'll drink yeah baby Otis smoothie come
on gamers Spanish flu bubonic plague
smallpox
oh god folks were melting the Arctic and
reviving deadly germs and they told me
plague doctor was an a viable career
path who's laughing now small peepee
because of mocs downvote during a
nuclear explosion there is a certain
distance of the radius where all the
frozen supermarket pizzas are cooked to
perfection oh that's actually a good
fair point there also at a distance
where the people are perfectly good the
flavor zone that's where I'll be gamers
where will you be when the inevitable
nuclear fallout happens my house has an
end problem that's so bad I actually can
recognize the smell of ant now trick the
end into thinking your hot ass hole is
an anthill which they can live in and
then when they've all crawled in you can
shot real hard and spray them
out all of the lawn Saeki pebble why
would you write that I feel bad for
doing that you should you should feel
bad that's actually a nice way to take
care of the ants cuz they they're
probably not hurt in the process
and they got more fertilizer for their
next ant hill thing or ant snack or
whatever it's called what would be the
worst place to find a used condom at the
bottom of a cup of coffee you just
finished drinking hope you like cream in
your coffee I like it in my G fuel is
yall's high school crush still fine hell
no she went from elegant to elephant
hell no last time I saw her she was
obese and had three kids which was
really sad to see because she used to
have five kids did she eat two of them
what what happened to that yeah what
does TSM stand for wrong answers only
TSM will start the Simpson movie oh my
god Oh God what's the definition of
trust two cannibals giving each other
bodies that's the most beautiful a true
love story would I read that I don't
feel better after any of these he was
teaching about Microsoft Word without
computer noob in Afghanistan they teach
Call of Duty without the NIC oh I get it
I get it
Viking is actually vegan horse riding
but I can't freakin back so who cares
you clearly haven't tried cringed
remember when you were young and your
sister would have her friends over and
he would try to piss loud as f so they
thought you had a big peepee don't need
to if your sister is already bragging to
her friends about your big peepee yeah
and also arranged we if peepee big then
technically people closer to water and
could be closer to what they're mean
people making less water splash sound so
really if you wanna show big peepee make
small peepee sound
smash like on this video that Puma looks
like a Disney princess trapped in a
Pumas body look at her eyes maybe that's
why he's banging it okay slavery
past present modern slaves are not in
Chains they're in depth I really hate it
when my credit card company waves me
sometimes when I'm too lazy to get up
and moisturize my lips I just stick a
finger in my beat be it now I'm not
reading that dogs are dumb animals they
will love you even if you're a piece of
poopie human being a cat you have to
earn a cat's respect and love it is a
higher standard animal also cat let's
deep throat this cactus because why not
people now eating glitter pills to make
their poop Sparkle Jesus Christ
imagine doing anal you take your pee pee
out and it's covered in sparkles epic I
think there's worse things you can spot
on your pee pee than sparkles after
doing poopoo if you know what I mean
gamers in 1965 a machine was patented to
deliver a baby using centrifugal force
the regime would spin you until the baby
came out and he would be caught in a net
at last is that a bad idea it was
patented dammit it was already patented
went on vacation in Okinawa Japan what
is that oh I wonder what you'd hear if
you put your ear to it the cry of a
thousand unborn babies hi big P big P P
big TT yeah what size huge you happy no
why
I'm guy and people say women have it
tough huh when you do something really
bad in a dream but then you wake up and
realize it's all fine oh my god yes good
thing they're still in the basement
thank God yes oh my god they didn't
escape
why does brain do that when you wake up
you're like oh god yes my life is not
such a complete mess after all how about
that
how much for a gram to feety ah I have a
warehouse who I thought that there was
some unlawful drug buying going on here
thankfully it's just keeping traffic
that's good I like that one guess what
you're adopted but we don't know it yet
because we can't read I just picture the
mom dying and they're going through
Hershey and find a photo album with that
photo in it they both have a mental
breakdown but then come to a realization
that they're not siblings and they just
bang each other now that would be an
epic gamer moment and who says there's
no more modern literature look at that
what a beauty thank you sir coffee
[Music]
amazing when you pretend to be gay to go
to the girls sleepover but then they
start passing a dildo around no pay no
game come on girl
you can't if you made it that far you
gotta come in Peter Pan
his powers kind of suck yeah he can fly
as long as he thinks happy thoughts
that seems exploitable why wasn't hook
ever on the deck of the ship like hey
Peter the Holocaust I don't have to read
the punch line I don't have to keep them
hooked what are some tips to stop biting
your own nails and we think that'll do
thank you ready thank you so much that's
so helpful when you think about how easy
it was for Elastigirl to give birth
wonder if she ever threatens to put them
back oh my god stop elderly woman
convinced the locals that she can suck
out talk sing by licking their eyeballs
see what happens when we stop burning
witches
I know it I knew something was wrong
what do you guys do at sleepovers we
sacrifice the weakest friend to the
devil why do you think Jimmy went who's
Jimmy exactly just want to sit on his
lap and feel him get hard leave them all
Santangelo leave their balls Santa's
alone this video is not getting monetize
no way tired of mosquitos stealing all
your blood simply inject poison into
your bloodstream and take revenge on
those annoying insects I did this to my
brother now he's on the ground with
ketchup all over him strange very
strange I must have poison in me because
mosquitos never bite me
all the time they go after my idea I've
never gotten a mosquito pipe what is
wrong with me am i alive helped me and
my has dead on the inside as I feel I am
helping my friend cut wood until I saw
this staring at me doc spider I live in
central Atari up we get ones this big
all the time want to know something
freaky they squirt this milky white
liquid if they feel threatened which I
assume is their venom you spelled arouse
wrong I didn't used to hate spiders but
they had them they have a lot of spiders
in UK like really the gross ones
sinky there's really stinky hate spiders
I hate spiders now and they make me wish
that something like I constantly debate
whether whether existence was worth it
or not you know you have people being so
stupid you're like all right yeah okay
and then there's some good likely how
Marseille is epic when my pugs but then
you have spiders that squid are white
liquid and this is like no you know what
maybe we should just quit everyone quit
maybe we should just quit cause us too
much pain and agony I don't know why
it's so popular I'm just gonna use the
toilet paper go to going back to good ol
toilet paper putting mushrooms in this
Spain spot as frame map has never looked
so cute wait why stop did they have to
bomb the cities I keep thinking about
this like they wanted to show how
powerful the atom bomb was I know they
were pissed about Pearl Harbor but like
why did they do it twice like those were
military bases am I missing something
like Pearl Harbor was a military base
here bombed to savelii civilian cities
is like what I don't understand war okay
i'm swedish some of these are just
trying too hard to be crazy to be edgy
i'll i'll say that why didn't logan paul
high-five rice gun i don't know but
that's not the last time he left an
asian hanging
alright guys hope you enjoyed this
episode of ready to review Kurt's
comment smash like if you did I would
really appreciate it since this video
will most likely not be monetized order
now to get it before Christmas 100
million club merged great gift for
everyone even yourself thank you guys
for watching see you tomorrow
[Music]
the hour of fart smells in poop grades
is coming marzia Edgar and buttons need
you
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne warranty is the game to play
I'm not supposed to have my opinion
about that but the prices
you